hi everybody I'm a clean and minimal map
API because that totally fits inside of
a lightning talk right all right
unfortunately there's gonna be a
tremendous amount of code that means
that this lightning talk is this and you
were the dog I'm very sorry but we're
gonna try and make it work
so I believe there are four fundamental
api's in a map data type view those for
our lookup insert update and remove and
yes they all line up perfectly and that
is part of why I love this API so let's
talk about look up look up on a map does
what you kind of expect it takes a key
looks up to see if it's in the map it
can fail and and we have to model that
so it's look at the return type to
understand how we model that lookup
result has a boolean so you can tell
whether or not it succeeded right
whether we found an entry you can also
get the key in the value if it has
actually found an entry makes sense
pretty straightforward insert we also
know pretty well right we want to insert
something into the map if we don't have
it we also need to understand whether
the insert took place so we have this
special return type okay the insert can
tell you you know did we actually insert
this into the map we also can get the
key and the value that we're talking
about here now it's a little bit tricky
to store this we actually have to have a
separate you know thing for the key and
for the insert and that and we store
these in a single location because most
people don't need to dig the key back
out so this doesn't even slow it down
very much and it keeps it nice and small
update is interesting because you don't
usually have update on our map types in
C++ which I really really dislike ok and
so what what update does is it inserts
if it's not in the map but if it is in
the map it updates the value anyways ok
now interestingly this still returns an
insert result because we actually want
the same set of information from insert
you know we want to did we actually
insert it and we need the key and the
value ok the last API that's fundamental
is remove here we give it a key we want
to remove an entry and we have a special
return type to make this a lot more
functional than most removals ok so you
can look at it we have a boolean to
indicate did we actually remove
something from the map and then we also
can get the key and the value
that we just removed and because we
actually removed them they're not on the
map anymore
so we can actually take ownership over
them if we want make sense
super super elegant alright and this is
just the surface so the question is do
we want to go deeper this is where you
go and vote for me come on
whoo-hoo all right so we're gonna go
deeper so there's some other api's that
are useful these aren't fundamental
because you can build these on the other
api's but you probably want to have them
and they may be able to be implemented
more efficiently we have square brackets
which is what you probably you're doing
most the time you're doing a lookup
right and it works the same way as
lookup but it just returns you a value
star now value starts a little bit weird
I would love to return an optional value
reference but I can't return an optional
reference so instead I return a value
star which is really lame because I can
do arithmetic on the return value but
anyways we'll fix that someday we also
have contains this just tests whether a
key is on the map okay transit boom we
can actually implement this a lot more
efficiently than an actual lookup and
lastly you can of course iterate over
the map that's pretty normal but we
actually didn't do a good job of
implement your map API we want
heterogeneous lookup so we need to add a
bunch of template goop to the stuff and
lightly thread is typed down but it
actually all still lines up it's all
still the same and it's just as
beautiful I think but when you also want
more interesting insert kind of
operations because it's really
inefficient for us it passed by value
every single time sure if we're mapping
to an INT it's fine but sometimes it's a
big object so we also have overloads of
these and it doesn't change the concept
but it lets us do things more
efficiently so we can pass a type erase
callable here so we used function right
for that and then this callable just
returns us a value and we don't call
this unless we need to do the insert and
we return the value of course update
always calls it because it has to always
do the update make sense pretty
straightforward we can do even more cool
stuff we can have an overload which
accepts a callable with this interesting
type and this actually calls this a
callable with the storage that it needs
to construct the value into and you can
imagine you have some lambda down here
and you can actually like do a little
placement mu over the storage to
actually construct this doesn't allocate
new memory but it allows you to totally
control the construction of your type
you know for power users they get this
powerful interface but if you just have
a simple use case you don't have to have
new api's
all right we can do even more
interesting things because your key type
may also be interesting and difficult to
construct so you can actually pass both
the key storage and the value storage
that you need to construct over okay so
we have a key storage we have a value
storage and you can write a lambda that
handles this now these lambdas will tend
to get a little bit more complicated you
might need to you know actually capture
something that you're going to use as
part of your state tricks for doing the
construction and then
do the placement new to actually set
things up okay a simple consistent
interface all the way through here and
for update of course this is always
called and for insert you only call it
when you're doing an insert people vague
look happy alright so should we go away
I don't know Michael
should we go even deeper how's my vote
I've got zero up here okay okay so what
do you people think are you gonna vote
are you gonna click for me I went too
fast come on almost okay there they go
maybe I think I'll have to keep going
all right you people are awesome so we
actually aren't done yet because all
maps should be small size optimized it
was incredibly common to have an empty
map to have a map with one element or a
very small number of elements and we
always want to optimize for that so we
have this little small size template
parameter in our map data type but this
is really annoying because this means
the type of our map has an
implementation to tailor it all the
small size is controlling is whether we
use some out of line storage for our
buffer or whether we have this like
small buffer in line right this is an
implementation to tail I don't want my
users to be interacting with this very
often so we need some way of getting rid
of this implementation to tail so we
introduce a map ref type okay this is a
reference type for maps that does a very
efficient type you racer of the small
size okay and it has the same API as map
right you can put as many api's as you
want here let's look at how we actually
implement this clever little type ratio
so also you have a conversion operator
to get that one all right so the way the
type racer works is like this inside of
the map ref we have a few data members
right we have a pointer to some some
struct of data members that's shared by
the actual map this way we don't have to
duplicate too much right we have the
small size but instead of it being in
the type we've moved it into a theta
right this is a nice little bit of Taif
eraser and then we have a pointer to
this Union support number this is a
pointer to the Union and that's
important because you know it's
sometimes we want to get this as a small
buffer but sometimes we actually need to
get at the buffer pointer and even
update the buffer pointer when this type
grows make sense
all right the other thing that's really
important for a map is that a lot of the
time you have a map that is not changing
and you just need to have read-only
access to it and for that we want to map
view type the still type races the small
size it only allows you to do Const
operation so it has a narrower API it's
also faster and I mean a lot faster it's
actually faster to use a map view than
it is to directly use the map if you're
going to make lots of operations on it
and so we really really like this how do
we actually make this work of course we
have you know conversion operators to
turn one of these things into a view and
inside the view we actually kind of go
ahead and decompose things we pull out
the size we pull out the small size we
pull out entropy which allows us to have
genuine lack of order in our in our hash
table and we put those directly into the
view and then we actually pre compute
the correct pointer to our buffer and
this may be a pointer to the small
buffer or it may be the value of buffer
pointer here and we do that when we
build the map view this means the map
view isn't valid across rehashing but it
means and that views really really fast
to use make sense so now we have a
read-only type of racist view so we have
a clean and minimal map API also I do
want to say tons of thanks to Hana and
Jeff for photoshop work and to Hana Jeff
and Michael for reviewing all of my
slides and to York for giving me an
actual Cherry Coke Zero thank you
[Applause]